[موسيقى]
بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر بالتوقيت
الرياضه نصيب شراير وهذه اخبار الساعه
رونالدو هدافه كره القدم يقدم لاعبا جديدا
في النصر ويؤكد جئت لكسر الارقام
والمشاركه في ثقافه النادي والبلد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هجمات وكيف كانت تثير وغضب القوميين
والمشرعين الروس ضد القاده تجاهلتم
المخاطر ووجبت المحاسبه
السلطات الايرانيه تدفع نحو تطوير القمع
والمحتجون يحرقون كالعاده صور سليمانيه
لكن متى في ذكرى مقتله
الجمهوريون يتسلمون اغلبيه مجلس النواب
ويسعون لتجاوز الخلافات
هديه العام الجديد
[موسيقى]
اسعد مؤقتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
تقديم تاريخي للهداف التاريخي لكره
كريستيانو رونالدو بعد انتقاله رسميا
لنادي النصر السعودي تقديم رونالدو عاده
يكون ضخما الامر لم يتغير كذلك في مرسول
بارك لملائمه تاريخه الكبير في ذلك الملعب
الواقع في الرياض حضر قرابه 25 الف مشجع
لحضور تقديم النجم البرتغالي الحائز على
خمس كرات ذهبيه افضل لاعب في العالم
رونالدو وخلال مؤتمر تقديمه اكد انه فضل
عرض نادي النصر على عروض الاوروبيات مشيرا
الى انه جاء للسعوديه من اجل كسر الارقام
القياسيه وما اكثر التي حطمها والمشاركه
في ثقافه النادي والبلد
[موسيقى]
توماتيكو مدريد
نعم صهيب بالفعل كانت تريلا غير عاديه
لعشاق النصر وعشاق كريستيانو على وجه
التحديد هنا في ملعب باسول بارك عندما تم
تقديم هذا اللاعب الاسطوري للمره الاولى
بشعار نادي سعودي نادي النصر وفي ملعب
مرسول مبارك الذي تزيل بشكل خاص
لكريستيانو رونالدو واستقباله وتقديمه
بشكل
غير مسبوق سواء ان كان على مستوى السعوديه
او حتى على مستوى الشرق الاوسط او مستوى
اسيا وحتى على مستويات حتى قارات اخرى لم
يتم تقديم لاعب بهذه الطريقه سوا في
اوروبا يتم محاكاه هذا التقديم بما تم في
عام 2009 عندما قدم كريستيانو رونالدو في
سنتياجو برنابيو عندما انتقل الى ريال
مدريد
وقادما
مبهرا جدا الحقيقه ولكن حدثنا عن المزيد
من التفاصيل في الكواليس عبد المحسن هل
هناك تفاصيل اخرى تبينت حول العقد بين
كريستيانو رونالدو النصر كذلك شاهدناه
كذلك مع
زملائه الجدد في فريق نادي النصر يبدو ان
العلاقه همم ستكون وديه بين زملائه في
النادي السعودي ما الذي تبين كذلك من
تفاصيل ربما همم فيما يتعلق بعلاقه
كريستيانو رونالدو مع النادي الجديد
بالفعل صهيب كان هنالك حديث كبير بانك
كريستيانو قادم
لمشاركات ربما شرفيه ولكن كريستيانو ما
قدمه ليوم سواء كان من همم تصاريح او حتى
تصرفات من خلال لقائه مع ال همم اللاعبين
واجتماعهم مع رئيس النادي وهذا ما تم بعد
المؤتمر الصحفي كان هنالك حديث من قبل
لاعبين النصر وكريستيانو تحديدا عن انه لم
يقدم الى
ليحصد المزيد من البطولات مع نادي النصر
وهو همم
صرح به ما لاعبين النصر في همم داخل غرفه
الملابس قبل ان يظهر بشكل مباشر للجمهور
بعد ذلك تحدث للجمهور عن الكثير من
امنياته عن ايضا همم امنياته بان يحطم
الارقام همم بعد ان حطمها في اوروبا يقول
بانه يريد ان يحطم الارقام في اسيا
فبالتالي هنالك حديث كبير من قبل
كريستيانو رونالدو بانه لم يقدم ولم تنتهي
مسيرتي هذا ما تحدث عن لم يقدم المشاركه
الشرافيه ولم ينت- تنتهي مسيرته بعد رد
على تصريحات همم الصحافه العالميه قال
بانه قادم للمشاركه بالفوز بالالقاب و
قابل ذلك جمهور النصر بتحيه كبيره جدا
كريستيانو صهيب لم يكن يستطيع التحدث في
بعض الاجزاء التي تواجد فيها في الملعب
نظرا للمنتخب الكميه هتافات كبيره جدا
جدا
لك عبد المحسن مباشره من الرياض
بعد هذا لاعب دولي لاعب مكسب للكره
السعوديه والعربي الاسيويه ونقل للكره
السعوديه في ثلاث دقائق الى العالميه
واصبح النادي الاعظم في العالم بحكم وجود
اللاعب فيه نادي النصر بالنسبه لصفقه
رونالدو انا شايف ان هي سبيري سمارت موف
من سوائل المملكه او نادي النصر وانا فاهم
ان هي برده صفقه تسويقيه ل 20 30 ان شاء
الله المملكه تقدر تعمل
تنظم كاس العالم
يروح معاهم و رونالدو ما شاء الله عليه و
الله يعرف يلعب عالمي
هذا هذا اللي نقدر نقوله عن صفقه كبيره
مثل صفقه رونالدو مع النصر
جدا نادره وهذه صفقه جديده وان شاء الله
يعني تتكرر وتصير يعني صفقات عاليه
والاسطوريه احسن منها
كريستيانو
وقال اذا على التقديم الاسطوري اليوم في
الرياض معلقا انا عالمي هذا هو هذه اول
صوره لكريستيانو رونالدو او اول بوست له
على حسابه على انستغرام الذي [__] 528
مليون متابع طبعا بعد هذا الاستقبال
الاسطوري بارك اليوم في الرياض بعد
انضمامه رسميه لنادي النصر السعودي
انتقال كريستيانو ليا النصر نتائجه ليست
رياضيه فقط بل تجاريه وتسويقيه على صعد
كثيره اولها تاثير على البث صحيفه
الرياضيه السعوديه كشفت ان هناك قنوات
تلفزيون عالميه تسعى لبث مباريات النصر
السعودي خلال الفتره المقبله من اجل
رونالدو ثانيا التاثير على مبيعات القمصان
وهنا وضع رونالدو متجر النصر في ورطه
لكنها ورطه قميص النجم البرتغالي نفدا
خلال ساعات من طرحها الكل يتهافت عليها
حتى خارج السعوديه الطلبات من خارج
السعوديه عاليه جدا بحسب مراسل العربيه
الامر الثاني هو مواقع التواصل انتقال
رونالدو الى النصر شكل نقله نوعيه كبيره
بالنسبه للنادي السعودي على مستوى وسائل
التواصل فصفحه النادي السعوديه على
انستغرام حققت نقله ضخمه بزياده عدد
المتابعين بالالاف عدد متابعي صفحه النادي
تضاعف ويتضاعف مع مرور الوقت الان بدا
يتجاوز 8 ملايين ونصف المليون متابع علما
ان عدد المتابعين قبل الاعلان عن الصفحه
كان بالكاد يفوق 800,000 متابع
هذه زياده الضخمه جعلت النبي السعوديه
تجاوز حتى انديه عالميه في عدد المتابعين
على انستغرام فعدم متابعين نصر باتي يتفوق
على متابعي انديه مثل روما الايطالي الذي
يملك حوالي 5 ملايين متابع كما ان النصر
بات يتجاوز ايضا انديه ذات شعبيه كبيره في
امريكا اللاتينيه مثل البالميراتسا
البرازيليه الذي لديه حوالي اربعه ملايين
متابعه لائحه الانديه التي تجاوزها مصر
تضم ايضا فرقا متالقه في الوقت الراهن مثل
نابولي المتصدر متصدر الدوري الايطالي
الذي لديه نحو ثلاثه ملايين متابع ومن بين
الانديه التي تجاوزها العالمي ايضا نجد
مرسي واستعمل الانجليزيه باير ليفربول
ثلاثه ملايين
من الرياض معنا عبدالله سبعه الباحث في
الشؤون التقنيه عبد الله اهلا بك معنا الى
اين يمكن ان يصل حجم الاستفاده التسويقيه
كذلك من انضمام كريستيانو رونالدو للنصر
الفائده التسويقيه اكبر من ما احنا نتصور
لازم نعرف ان انضمام كريستيانو رونالدو
للنادي النصر اااا اثر جدا كبير على
الاسواق لازم نعرف انه كمان كريستيانو
رونالدو يوم انضم الى مانشستر يونايتد
وايضا يوفنتوس
قفزه في القيمه السوقيه للنادي انضمام
كريستيانو رونالدو همم كانت صحبه كثيره
تتكلم عنه لدرجه ان بعض الصحف اصبحت تتكلم
ان السعوديه قد تكون هي الوجه العالميه
للاعبين الاوروبيين في نهايه مسيرتهم
الكرويه عكس امريكا في السابق كانت امريكا
هي من تحت ظل لاعبين في نهايه مسيرتهم
الكرويه الان السعوديه قد تكون هي الوجهه
خاصه مع قرب السعوديه من اوروبا وايضا حجم
الدوري والقيمه السوقيه الكبيره حاليا
اللاعبين وايضا وجود بطوله دوري ابطال
اسيا عبد الله هناك من يتحدث عن فائده
تسويقيه ليس فقط لنادي النصر او الدوري
السعودي او للرياضه السعوديه بل يمتد الى
مساله اكبر مساله همم الترويج كذلك
للسعوديه كذلك عالميا همم
وهناك من هنا من يربط مساله العقد الاضخم
همم طبعا هناك حسب مصادر اعلاميه انه 200
مليون يورو عقد رونالدو مع النصر همم هل
بالامكان ان تكون المداخيل همم تتجاوز
كثيرا هذا المبلغ الذي دفع لرونالدو
بعض المداخيل ما هي اموال بعض المداخيل هي
تجيء بطريقه
ايضا كقيمه للدوري نفسه على سبيل المثال
الان بامكان اي نادي مفاوضه اي لاعب
والحصول على توقيع لاعب لان كريستيانو
رونالدو موجود عندك في الدوري في القيمه
السوقيه اساسا راح تختلف راح تكون فيه
امور كثيره مختلفه على الماده السنوات
القادمه ايضا لا ننسى ان السعوديه عازمه
على استضافه كاس العالم 20 30 رونالدو قد
يساهم في رفع خطوط السعوديه في الاستفاده
من رونالدو في الدوري السعودي وايضا
الاستفاده من استضافه
كاس العالم وغيرها من المناسبات الرياضيه
المختلفه في امور ابعد من فقط كره قدم
نادي معين انما في صوره اكبر قادمه همم
السعوديه على مدى سنوات القادمه
دوري على مدى سنوات القادمه كذلك عبد الله
مساله اخرى تبدو اللافته في انضمام
كريستيانو رونالدو غير البعد الرياضي كذلك
وجود عائلته الى جانبه شركه جورجينا
واطفالهما كذلك كانوا حاضرين على مستوى
السوشيال ميديا هذا الحضور كذلك كيف يكون
انعكاسه وكذلك على ثقافه المجتمع على همم
صوره البلد كذلك السعوديه والسعوديه التي
تشهد حراكا وتغيرا كبيرين خاصه مع رؤيه
راح يكون الاثر جدا كبير خلال الايام مو
ما نقدر نقول السنوات خلال الايام القادمه
لان اختلاط رونالدو بالعادات والتقاليد
راح يوضح صوره كانت غائبه طوال السنوات
الماضيه راح يكون رح يوصل صوت مختلف قد
يكون اثر كبير جدا ممكن احنا ما نتصور
خلال سنوات الحاليه لكن خلونا نتفائل بشكل
كبير ان المستقبل واعد بشكل جدا كبير مو
فقط للدوري السعودي انما بشكل بصوره اكبر
للسعوديه بشكل عام عبد الله السبع شكرا
جزيلا مباشره من الرياض
ولا قبل ان نغلق ملف رونالدو الذي
سنتناوله اكيد في نهايه النشره مع الاخبار
الرياضيه نتابع معكم هذا الفيديو من
المؤتمر الصحفي رونالدو اذا لديه احتفال
شهير عندما يسجل الاهداف وخلال مؤتمر
تقديمه لاعبا في النصر قام احد الصحفيين
بعمل الاحتفال ذاته دعونا نشاهد رد فعل
النجم البرتغالي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه حيث
تعرضت مدينه دمياط والاحياء المجاوره لها
لقصف عنيف من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه وخلف
القصف الاوكرانيه على دنيا 17 اصابه
وقتلين من جانبها رده روسيا على قصف مركزي
تجنيد الروسي في دونيتك بعده ضربات اهمها
قصف قاعده تجنيد عسكريه يتواجد بها قرابه
200 جندي اوكراني في منطقه
من جهتها اعلنت هيئه الاركاني في الجيش
الاوكراني تنفيذا 13 هجوم صاروخيا ومدفعيه
على مواقع على القوات الروسيه خلال 24
ساعه اشار الجيش الاوكراني وفي بيانه الى
احباط محاولات تواغل الروسيه في 15 منطقه
بدنيتك وتام جيش الاوكراني روسيا بقصف
مناطق ماهوله في الضفه اليمنى من نهر دن
برو بخرسون مؤكدا ان تهديد ضربات الجويه
والصاروخيه الروسيه على البنيه تحتيه
الحيويه في جميع انحاء اوكرانيا لا يزال
مستمر
كما اعلنت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان
الجيش الاوكراني اسقط نحو 500 طائره من
دون طيار ايرانيه الصنع منذ سبتمبر
الماضيه واكد المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ان قوه الدفاع الجوي دمرت جميع
الطائرات المسيره التي اطلقتها روسيا في
هجومها المكثفه في خلال عطله راس السنه
البالغ عددها 84 طائره
من جهتها اعلنت هيئه او اكد الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي ان هناك خططه روسيه لحمله
طويله من هجمات الطائرات من دون طيار
هدفها اضعاف الروح المعنويه لاوكرانيه
مشيرا الى انه تلقى تقارير الاستخباراتيه
تشير الى ان موسكو ستنشن الهجمات باستخدام
طائرات شاهد ايرانيه الصنع
مين معي
باستخدام طائرات شاهد المسيره ومن المحتمل
ان يكون الهدف من وراء ذلك استنزاف شعبنا
وانظمه الدفاع عن الجويه وقطاع الطاقه
لدينا نحن نتصرف ونفعل كل ما بوسعنا
لافشالهم من تحقيق اهدافهم
اثارت الغارات الجويه الاوكرانيه الاخيره
على معسكر نتابع للقوات الروسيه رداتها
فعل وانتقادات داخل روسيا حيث طلب قوميون
ومشرعون بمعاقبه قاده عسكريين اتهموهم
بتجاهل المخاطر التي تسببت بمقتل 63 جنديا
من القوات الروسيه في مكه بدنياك ويبن
المنتقدون مطالباتهم هذه على ان الجنود
كانوا يقيمون قرب مستودعا للذخيره في
الموقع الذي اصيب بصواريخ هايمارس امريكيه
الصنع فيما ذكر مدونه عسكريون الروس ان
القاده كانوا على علم بان المبنى الذي
تعرض للقصف في مكه
كبير بسبب تخزين الذخيره يقع في مرمى
الصواريخ الاوكرانيه من جانبه طلب
الرئيس السابق لمجلس الاتحاد طلبه بمسائله
جنائيه للمسؤولين الذين سمحوا بتكديس جنود
في مبنى دون توفير حمايه لهم
نتابع مع مراسيلينا من موسكو ومنكياف عبد
الجواد الرشد وحذيفه عادل مرحبا بكما عبد
الجواد ابدا معك هل سيكون هناك محاسبه
وعقاب كما يطالب القوميون للقاده
العسكريين بعد استهداف الجنود الروسي في
مكيفا
مساء الخير صهيب لك ولي حذيفه حتى هذه
اللحظه رسميا لا يتم الحديث رغم كل
الانتقادات الكبيره من اطراف عده بما يخص
ما حدث في دينيس ك- ليله طبعا راس السنه
وسقوط 10 القتلى والجرحى بضرباته اوكرانيه
طبعا العديد من الاصوات في البلاد خرجت
وتحدثت عن سوء التنظيم وسير العمليه
العسكريه والجميع اصبح يعود للوراء قليلا
ويتذكر وينشر كلمات الرئيس شيشاني رمضان
قديره الذي انتقد سير العمليه مرات عده في
السابقه لكن طبعا اليوم الجميع اصبح يتحدث
وينظر بعين الواقع الى ما حدث هناك بانه
امر الصعب طبعا وسقوط هذا العدد الكبير
خاصه ان الجنود الذين سقطوا هم من من يعني
من تلك الفئه التي تم تعبئهم خلال الفتره
الماضيه وكانوا قصفهم يقومون بارسال رسائل
نصيه ورسائل عبله عبر وثائق اخرى الى
ذويهم يهنونهم باعياد طبعا راس الميلاد
راس السنه والميلاد لكن الوضع حتى هذه
اللحظه لم يخرج اي شيء رسمي ينبئ او يتحدث
عن معاقبه احد باعتبار ان العمليه
العسكريه اليوم فيدخل في اصعب يعني هو
واقفها نلاحظ بان موسكو بدات بالرد بشكل
جدي كبير على ما حدث ليله راس السنه
الاعداد
الاوكرانيين تمكنوا من تحديد المواقعهم
بعد ما فتحوا جوالاتهم همم وقاموا
باستهدافهم بصواريخ حذيفه في كيف اسالك
هنا عن الترقب الاوكراني للرد الذي بدا
بالفعل كما قال همم عبد الجواد ولكن كيف
تتحضر اوكرانيا لمختلف السيناريوهات بعد
هذه الضربه الموجعه التي اعت بها روسيا
نعم تحياتي صهيب لك ولزمين عبد الجواد
طبعا باشر الاتحاد الروسي بتنفيذ ضربات
استمرت لثلاثه ايام هذه الغارات الجويه
استهدفت العاصمه كيف ومعظم المدن
الاوكرانيه بمسيرات عديده ولكن الدفاع
الجوي الاوكراني استطاع ان يسقط جميع هذه
المسرات ولم ينفذ صاروخ واحد الى الى يعني
الوجه التي وجهها ولا طائره مسيره كان
هنالك اصابات قليله جدا جراء الشضايا سقطت
من احد من احد الصواريخ ومن ايضا طائره
مسيره ولكن هذه الضربه اليوم كان هنالك
ضربات جديده لجيش اوكراني كما سماها بيان
ال- همم هيئه الاركان المشتركه الاوكرانيه
همم
يعني همم النصر جديد في شوكولاته ايضا
اليوم ضربه صاروخيه لمراكز تجمع القوات
الروسيه وقال البيان انه تم قتل
وما بين قتيل وجريح 500 فرد من افراد
القوات المسلحه الروسيه كذلك ايضا همم في
منطقه الدونيسك تم تدمير 11 دبابه وتم
السيطره على طريق الاستراتيجي صفاتها
تفكرين وهذا الطريق تقاتل القوات
الاوكرانيه من اجله منذ عده ايام واليوم
اعلن رسميا ان السيطر عليه وهذا طريق هام
جدا الان القوات التي تقدم في كريم هي
عاجزه عن الحصول على الامدادات تتخذ طرق
رائعه جدا
حذيفه وعبد الجواد ارجو ان تبقى معي ساعود
اليكما في زاويه اخرى
او لا سنكتب في اذن معكما بهذا ال- القدر
على المتابع معكما همم في نشرها لاحقا اذا
تطورات الوضع الميداني في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات الاحتجاجات في ايران حيث اشار
تقرير لصحيفه الفرنسيه لخلافات داخل الحرس
الثوري بسبب التظاهرات كما اوضح ان النظام
يتجه لتطوير مزيد من وسائل القمع في اثناء
نشر النظام الايراني مجددا قوته العسكريه
في مدينه جنرالدا الكرديه في ظل حاله
غليان تشهدها المدينه عقب قتل عناصر امنيه
لمحتجنه السبت الماضي يتزمن هذا التطور مع
استعدادات اهالي المدينه لاقامه مراسم
اربعينيه سبعه قتلى سقطوا في المسيرات
الاحتجاجيه بانيران افراد الامن الشهره
الماضيه
وفي سياق المتصل ذكرته وسائل الاعلاميه
ايرانيه ان السلطات القضائيه في طهران
وجهه اتهامات لمواطنين فرنسيين اثنين
ومعهما مواطن بلجيكي بالتجسس والعمل ضد
الامن القومي الايراني وتاتي الاتهامات
ضمن حمله الاعتقالات العشوائيه التي
تنفذها السلطات الامنيه بتهمه التحريض
واثاره الشغب
في السياق وصلت لاعبه الشطرنج الايرانيه
صار خادم الشريعه الى اسبانيا لطلب اللجوء
بعد تلقيها تحضيرات بعدم العوده الى ايران
رويترز قالت ان خادم تلقت مكالمات هاتفيه
متعدده من افراد قريبين منها حذروها بعدم
العوده الى ايران مخافه اعتقالها من طرف
قوه الامن وهذا لظهورها بدون حجاب في
العاب الشطرنج في دوله كازاخستان
المحتجون في ايران لا يفوتن اي فرصه او
مناسبه دون اظهار رفضهم لرموز النظام
الايراني الذي يوصل قمعه مظاهراتهم بل
والتطوير وسائل القمع منذ انطلاق
التظاهرات في سبتمبر تحرق صور قاسم
سليماني نعم لكن اختيار اليوم تحديدا
لاحرق صوره مجددا امر له رمزيه فاليوم تحل
الذكرى الثالثه لمقتل قائد فيلق القدس
السابق في طهران ومحافظه اذربيجان الشرقيه
اختار المحتجون التعبير عن غضبهم من خلال
اضرام النار في صور عملاقه لسليمان سليمان
قتل في غاره امريكيه استهدفته سنه 2020
قرب مطار بغداد في العراق
[موسيقى]
ذكرى اخرى ثالثه تحل خاصه بايران ايضا وهي
اسقاط الحرس الثوري لطائره الركاب
الاوكرانيه وهنا ايضا الاحتجاجات موجوده
الداعي لها هذه المره جمعيه اهالي الضحايا
الاربعاء الثامن من يناير 2020
اجتهدف الصواريخ الحارثي الثوري الايراني
طائره تابعه للخطوط الجويه الاوكرانيه
وتس 179 راكبا كانوا على متن تلك الطائره
بعد وقت قصير من اقناعها اسقط الحرس
الثوري الايراني الطائره تلك الرحله في
اول موقف رسمي انكر السلطات الطيران
الايرانيه اصابه الطائره وعزت حادثه
التحطم الى خطا انتقلي فيما اوضحت السلطات
الاوكرانيه بعد مزايرتها في البدايه الى
التفسير الايراني ان اسقاط الطائره بصاروخ
كان احد نظريات الرئيسيه التي تعمل عليها
اما المسؤولون الامريكيون والكنديون
والبريطانيون فقد صرحوا ان الطائره قد تم
اسقاطها بواسطه الصاروخ ارض جو ايراني
بعدها اقر فيلق الحارس الثوري بانهم اسقط
الطائره بعد ان اعتقد خطا بانها صاروخ
كروز امريكيه
ثلاث سنوات مرت على جريمه لا تزال
اصدقائها تتردد جريمه قتل فيها من قتل
فيما لا يزال مرتكبها بعيدا عن يد القانون
الدولي اما اهالي الضحايا فما بيدهم حيله
سوا دعوات الاحتجاج او الاضراب عصام عبد
السلام العربيه
مجلس النواب الامريكي اذا يفشل في اغتيال
رئيس في الجوله الثانيه من التصويت طبعا
الاغلبيه هنا للجمهوريين سنتابع هذا الملف
لاحقا في اخبار الساعه وبعد الفاصل نعود
ونتابع ردا على اعتراض الصين على اختبارات
كرونا الحكومه الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد متابع من امريكا كما
ذكرت قبل الفاصل فشله مجلس النواب
الامريكي قبل قليل في اختيار رئيسا له في
الجوله الثانيه من التصويت على الشاشه هذه
الصور المباشره لجلسه مجلس النواب الذي
حظي فيها الجمهوريون الانبياء الاغلبيه
بعد انتخابات التجديد النصف في شهر نوفمبر
الماضي طبعا المرشح الاوفر حظا من
الجمهوريين هو كيف في المرشح الاوفر حضن
كي يخلف نانسي فلوسي زعيمه الديمقراطيين
التي كانت طبعا مجلس النواب وكانت
المشهوره باعدائها الشديد لرئيس الجمهوريه
السابق
هل مجلس الذي تسلم له الجمهوريون بعد
الانتخابات النصفيه الاخيره قد يحمل انباء
انصار الرئيس السابق لكن اذا تجاوز
الجمهوريون خلافاتهم حظوظه الجمهوريه كما
ذكرت كلمه كبيره لخلافه نانسي بعد ما رش
هو الجمهوريون بشكل رسمي
والتخطيط هنا لامور عده منها وقف الدعم
الامريكي لاوكرانيا لكن في البدايه عليهم
تجاوز خلافتهم الداخليه حول الرئيس وفي
حال فوزي مار كارتي فسيكون بصدد تجهيز
هديه لدونالد ترامب بحسب نيوز ويك حيث
سيتحرك لالغاء تمويل مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه الاف بي اي الذي يتهممه موال
ترامب بمحاوله الانتقام من الرئيس السابق
بعد تشكيكه في نتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه
السابقه وفي حال نجاح كبير سيكون بامكان
الجمهوريين محاوله وقت تمويل اي تحقيقات
او ملاحقات قضائيه في حلقه ترامب لكن اي
تعديلات يجريها الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب
بحاجه لموافقه مجلس الشيوخ الذي يسيطر
عليه الديمقراطيون مما يعني ان اي محاوله
لالغاء تمويل لتحقيقات مع ترامب قد تؤدي
الى مواجهه بين الحزبين في المجلسين
متابعه من واشنطن مع مراسلنا حسين الطود
حسين اذا للمره الثانيه هناك فشل في مجلس
النواب الانتخاب رئيس له ما هي الاسباب
هناك اسباب عديده ولكن المتشددون كما
يصفون من الجمهوريين
طلبوا مقارتي بتقديم العديد من التعهدات
والتنازلات اييه من اجل الدوره 18 من
الجلسه او الدوره التشريعيه ااه مكارتي في
الحقيقه خلال الايام الماضيه بالفعل
اعطاهم ضمانات وقدم تنازلات خاصه فيما
يتعلق باليه عزل رئيس مجلس النواب بدل ان
يتطلب ذلك همم نصف اصوات الاعضاء
الجمهوريين في المجلس همم
خفض العتبه عتبه الاصوات على خمسه اصوات
من الجمهوريين ولكن همم في نفس الوقت ولم
يعطيهم ضمانات بشان عدم تدخل رئيس مجلس
النواب في الانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب
الجمهوري لصالح بعض المرشحين على حساب
المرشحين اخرين هذا ما دفع هؤلاء
الجمهوريه المتشددين الى الاعتبار همم
الضمانات التي اعطاها ليست كافيه يعني
العديد منهم يتهمونه ويقولون انه لم يكن
يدافع بشكل كافي عن الرئيس همم السابق
دونالد ترامب همم خلال همم
التحقيقات السادس من يناير من هو فقط
من الجلسه كنا نشاهد نانسي بلوس الرئيس
السابق زعيمه الديمقراطيين في مجلس النواب
التي ستغادر مقعدها طبعا في رئاسه المجلس
بعد وصول الجمهوريين للاغلبيه في المجلس
هنا اسالك حسين ماذا ننتظر الان بعد الفشل
للمره الثانيه في التصويت لصالح كبير ماذا
سيحصل الان
سيحصل ستكون هناك جوله ثالثه ورابع وخامسه
حتى يتم انتخاب رئيس مجلس النواب لا يمكن
لهذا المجلس ان يبدا اذا لم يكن هناك رئيس
لمجلس النواب الجمهوريون لازم يستطيع ان
يحكموا اذا لم ينتخبوا رئيسا في هذا لهذا
المجلس كمان هو لن يكون هناك قسم النواب
الان ينتظرون ان يتم انتخاب رئيس مجلس ااه
نواب لكي يتم القسم اداء سوريا كل ذلك
متوقف الان على هذه العمليه ولكن في ظل
الخلاف من الجمهوريين وفي ظل همم اتحاد
الديمقراطيين خلف همم مرشحهم حصل الان همم
حكيم جفرس حصل على همم واثنين
103 اصوات فقط بسبب تصوير 19
نعم هذا في الكونجرس طبعا حدث متفاعل ولكن
ايضا في العاصمه واشنطن كذلك همم سنذهب
الى موضوع اخر هام من البيت الابيض حيث
اكدت الخارجيه الامريكيه مشاهدينا في بيان
لها قبل قليل تعليقا على اقتحام وزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي ات ماربين كثير
باحات المسجد الاقصى اكدت ان هذه التصرفات
يمكنها ان تفاقم التوتر وتزيد من العنف من
جهته اوضح البيت الابيض ان واشنطن تؤيد
بحزم الحفاظ على الوضع الراهن للمواقع
المقدسه في القدس قبل ذلك اكد مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي رفضه لاي عمل احادي يقوض
عمليه السلام في الشرق الاوسط وطلب المجلس
بنيامين نتنياهو بالالتزام بتعهداته
بالحفاظ على الوضع القائم للمواقع
المقدسات اذا همم حسين هل هناك المزيد من
المواقف من الاداره الامريكيه فيما يتعلق
بهذه الخطوه التي عدت استفزازيه وقامت
بالادانتها العديد من الدول العربيه همم
يعني اقتحام همم المسجد الاقصى لباحه
المسجد الاقصى
صهيب الامريكيون دائما يفضلون دبلوماسيه
ويريدون الحفاظ على الامور كما هي عليها
الان لا يريدون تصعيدا لا من هذا الجانب
ولا من هذا الجانب لهذا كان هناك تخوف
وهمم من ان تؤدي اي عمليه استفزاز الى
تدهور الامور الى ما لا يحمد عقبات كما
يقال لهذا السبب هم يدعون جميع الاطراف
دبلوماسيه على الاقل الى ضبط النفس وعلى
عدم اتخاذ خطوات اا قد تؤدي الى تدهور
الامور الى حالات اسوا من هذا المنطلق
نسمع هذه المواقف الامريكيه هنا ان كان في
البيت الابيض او في الخارجيه وحتى في
الكونغرس الامريكي جمالا ايضا ان هناك دعم
كبير لعمليه السلام هم يريدون ان تكون
هناك علاقه جيده بين الدول العربيه وبين
اسرائيل
ويرون ان في هذه التصرفات الامور قد تسوق
وقد لا يتم همم توسيع او تطوير عمليه
السلام بين بين اسرائيل وبين دول العربيه
في المنطقه عشان نطول شكرا جزيلا مباشره
واشنطن
وبالحديث عن الادهانات العربيه والدوليه
الاقتحام بن غفير اعربت الخارجيه السعوديه
عن ادانه المملكه للممارسات الاستفزازيه
للمسؤولي الاسرائيلي باقتحام باحات المسجد
الاقصى وعبره الوزاره في بيان عن اسس
المملكه لما تقوم به اسرائيل من ممارسات
تقود جهود السلام الدوليه وتتعرض مع
المبادئ والاعراف الدوليه في احترام
المقدسات الدينيه كما اعربت مصر الاردن
الامارات الكويت البحرين وقطر وجامعه
الدول العربيه عن ادانت اقتحام المسؤول
الاسرائيلي لباحه المسجد الاقصى
للمزيد معنى مراسلنا من القدس زياد حلبي
زياد اهلا بك معنا
يائيل لبيد رئيس الوزراء السابق قال ان
خطوه بن غفير هذه في باحه المسجد الاقصى
وضعت اسرائيل في مشكله مع نصف دول العالم
هل هناك المزيد من المواقف الاسرائيليه
اولا دعنا نشير الى ان ثمه انفجارا سمع
دويه قبل بعض الوقت شرق منطقه دير البلح
بالقرب من السياج الحدودي على ما يبدوا
ناتج من اطلاق صاروخ من وسط قطاع غزه تجاه
المستوطنات الاسرائيليه وفقه ادعاء
الاسرائيليين لم يسقط في الاراضي
الاسرائيليه ربما سقط بمحادات داخل قطاع
غزه لكن كما توقعنا منذ ساعات الصباح بان
صاروخا او اثنين قد يطلق من قطاع غزه بدون
ان شك بان همم هناك الان حاله الترقب في
اسرائيل بسبب هذا الاقتحام لبن فير
المعارضه الاسرائيليه منذ الامس اساسا
بدات بمهاجمه كبير والان الخطوه التي نفذ
وقالت انها استفزازيه وقد تؤدي الى تصعيد
واراقه دماء وبالتالي همم ايضا قد تؤدي
الى التعقيد بوضع اسرائيل
تعرضت تسونا من ردود الفعل العربيه
والدوليه طيب على ذكر هذا التصعيد هل همم
يعني همم سيبقى الموضوع وفق يعني الرد كا
صاروخ او صاروخين فقط مثل الصاروخ الذي
اطلق قبل قليل من غزه ام نحن امام سيناري
مشابه لما قام به شارون همم قبل الانتفاضه
زياد
دعني اذكرك شارون عندما قام بالاقتحام عام
2000 في اليوم الاول لم يحدث شيء في اليوم
الثاني اندلعت انتفاضه كانت همم
الاخطر في همم العلاقه المتفجره بين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين راح ضحيتها
الالاف بدون ان شكله لا يمكن التكهن طبعا
تم اختلاف جوهري بين تلك الفتره وهذه
الفتره وبين شكل الاقتحام هذه المره وما
تم زمن شارون كان همم
الاتحاد هذه الزياره تمت خلسه اليوم في
ساعات الصباح عندما كان همم
اقصد المسجد الاقصى وما الى ذلك وبالتالي
يصعد مع ذلك التكهد بدون مشاكل هناك حاله
في اسرائيل كما سبق وشرحنا وقد يكون هناك
اذا ما تاكد اطلاق الصاروخ قد يكون هناك
ايضا رد اسرائيلي بغاره على احد المواقع
ايضا داخل القطاع زياده شكرا جزيلا من
القدس
[موسيقى]
الى السودان حيث اعلن نائب رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني محمد حمدان دجله تجنيد
قوات خاصه في ولايه دارفور ولايات دارفور
الخمس منعا للاحتكاك القبلي ووصف الدجله
في بيان نشره السياده ما حدث من خسائر
واضرار جراء التعدي على بعض مناطق محليه
محليه بليل بولايه جنوب دارفور وصفها
بالمحنه مؤكدا ضروره وضع خارطه طريق
الواضحه لمنع تجدد مثل هذه الاحداث
والله ما نتخلى عنكم الا غير ما ترجعوا
بيوتكم
وتستغلوا ونواصل معكم
والدوله هتوفر لكم
تماما عن باقي التحقيقات لازم نصل فوقهم
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه اسبوع صعب مقبل
على بريطانيا خمسه ايام متتاليه من
اضرابات القطارات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تواجه بريطانيا هذا
الاسبوع اعنف سلسله من اضرابات القطارات
حتى الان حيث ستستمر الاضرابات خمسه ايام
متتاليه في شهر يناير الحليب وسينفذ موظفه
السكك الحديديه في نقابه عمال السكك
الحديديه والبحريه والنقل اضربين مده كل
واحد منهما 48 ساعه في الثالث والرابع
والسادس والسابع من يناير اضافه الى اضراب
نقابه رجال الاطفاء في الخامس من الشهر
الحالي وتمثل الاضرابته تصعيدا اخر حرف
النزاع المتزايد بين النقابات والحكومه
على الاجور بحسب صحيفه
[موسيقى]
عربه الخليجيه الفلسطينيه
وهي غير مبرره
مستعدون للتواصل مع العالم للتغلب على
رائحه كورونا لكننا نعتقد ان قيود الدخول
التي فرضتها بعض الدول على الصين تفتقر
الى الاساس العلمي وبعض الممارسات غير
المقبوله الصين تعارض بشده محاولات
التلاعب باجراءات الوقايه من الوباء
ومكافحته لاغراض سياسيه وسنتخذ الاجراءات
المناسبه وفقا لمبدا المعامله بالمثل
من جهه عرضه الاتحاد الاوروبي على الصين
تزويدها بلقاحات المجانيه لكوبل 19 مع
ارتفاع عدد الاصابات
سياستها صفر كوميدي واوضح متحدث باسم
المفوضيه الاوروبيه ان الصينيه لم ترد بعد
على العرض الاوروبيه فيما لم يحدد المتحدث
كميه اللقاحات التي عرضها الاتحاد
الاوروبي على الصين او الشركات المصنعه
لها
في اثناء قالت رئيسه الوزراء الفرنسيه ان
الحكومه تؤدي واجبها لحمايه الفرنسيين من
خلال طلب الاختبارات الطبيه للمسافرين
القادمين من الصين
تؤدي الحكومه واجبها في حمايه الفرنسيين
من خلال طلب الاختبارات المسافرون من
الصين الى فرنسا يتعهدون بقبول اجراء
الاختبار عند وصولهم ما يساعدنا في الحصول
على بيانات حول تطور الفيروس والتاكد من
وجوده نفعل ذلك مع احتراما كامل لقواعد
منظمه الصحه العالميه وصنوان وصل
من ثلاث سنوات
صارمه قرارات الصين تعليق هذه السياسه ما
رفع من عدد الاصابات لكن ما تاثير هذا
القرار على ثاني اقوى اقتصاد في العالم
[موسيقى]
اخبار الساعه تفكيرهم بابرز العلوي
رونالدو هداف كره القدم يقدم لاعبا جديدا
في النصر ويؤكد لكسر الارقام والمشاركه في
ثقافه النادي والبلاد
[تصفيق]
هجمات وكيف كانت تطير وغضب القوميين
والمشرعين الروس ضد القاده تجاهلتم
المخاطر ووجدت المحاسبه
السلطات الايرانيه تدفع نحو تطوير القمع
والمحتجون يحرقون كالعاده صور سليمان لكن
متى في ذكرى مقتله
[موسيقى]
الجمهوريون يتسلمون اغلبيه مجلس النواب
ويسعون لتجاوز الخلافات ومنح ترامب ذهبيه
العام الجديد
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]